[Music]
no
the place is full of nothing but blood
and death can someone please
tell me what the hell is going on here
wow well
ethan winters what the hell was that
let's see what you're really made of
ethan rancheros
hey everyone and welcome to the second
resident evil showcase
i'm your host brittany bronbacher and i
am so excited to be your guide through
today's experience
we're going to hear from the resident
evil team today and they have so much
new content for you
another trailer new gameplay and more
news for resident evil village which is
right around the corner
coming to us on may 7th we'll also be
sharing the latest on the 25th
anniversary of the series
and some fun surprises that go along
with that so stay tuned
to kick us off i have the honor of
introducing june takeuchi the executive
producer of the franchise
[Music]
hi i'm june takeuchi executive producer
on resident evil
due to your continued support the
franchise has reached its 25th
anniversary
thank you so much 25 whole years
supported by so many of our fans when i
look back over the years and think about
when we first started this project with
shinji mikami
i never would have imagined that it
would turn into such a long
lasting franchise even now i want to see
the series continue to succeed
through your continued support now we've
prepared the latest trailer for our
upcoming title
resident evil village it's a game
jam-packed full of entertainment and
horror
and it has a huge breath of content so
brace yourselves when you play
well then without further ado please
enjoy
as the midnight moon rises on black
wings
we await the light at the end
in life and in death glory to mother
[Music]
miranda
but you're whining we're almost there
rose where are you
if there are any survivors out there
come to my
to louise's house near the fields
[Music]
oh no they're coming who is
what the hell was that
stop shouting
tell me what is going on around here it
doesn't make any sense
mother miranda has always protected us
you escaped my little brother's idiot
games did you
let's see how special you are
is this all that's left from your entire
village all that's
left there is no one left
we can bust out with this
[Applause]
likans and gentlemen
we thank you for waiting and now that
the games begin
there is no safe every sorry fast out
there has been ripped in a hack
tomorrow we'll all be dead no let me go
for ethan
ethan winters welcome
get off of me stay the [ __ ] down
i gotta say i'm surprised you made it
this far it'd be a shame if something
happened to you now
you killed mia now do me and finish the
job
there is so much to break down there i
know we cannot wait to find out what
chris's involvement is
now in the last showcase we promised
that another demo was coming this spring
sometimes me it won't involve casualty
time with lady dimitrisk
but i don't think the internet would
mind that let's pass it to
konda producer on resident evil village
to tell us more about that upcoming
gameplay demo
kondasan thank you so much for joining
us again today
thank you for the introduction brittany
hi everyone
i'm sushi khanda producer on resident
evil village
resident evil village has been created
with the concept of a beautiful yet
terrifying village in mind
and we have poured a passion into
creating this experience for our fans
of course it also has the combat
resource management
and horror elements you expect from
resident evil
we've also made sure there's plenty of
gameplay content as well
in the previous showcase we told you
that we'd have another demo ready for
you across multiple
well i'm happy to announce that the next
demo experience will be available on
playstation 5
playstation 4 xbox series x
xbox one steam and stadium
in new of the game event that we were
unable to hold
we have prepared a special day where you
can experience
resident evil village here are the
details on what need to be available
you'll have a total of 60 minutes to
explore
both the village and castle areas
you're free to spend one full hour for
both stages
or choose which one you want to play
it's up to you where you spend your
survival horror experience
playstation 5 and playstation 4 owners
will also get early access as well
we've titled it 8 hours in village
we have the details for you here
in honor of resident evil village being
the eighth major
installment of the franchise you will
have an
8 hour window to try out the demo for 30
minutes
playstation players will have early
access to the village section first
followed by the castle section for the
arri access players
feel free to also stream and share your
play through to the world
we hope that with your help we will be
able to show off the demo to everyone
and for the multiple platform demo we
hope that all players from
all over the world will be able to enjoy
the resident evil village demo
finally players will be able to pre-load
the demo ahead of time
playstation 5 and playstation 4 owners
are able to pre-download the demo
starting today
please visit our official website for
more details
we hope you enjoyed this upcoming sneak
peek
at the next generation of survival
horror
i'm so torn where to spend my time do i
spend it in the village
or the castle let us know what your plan
is
but in the meantime what if i told you
there's another surprise in store
any guesses let's see if we can get
director maureen masasato to tell us
what he knows
hi everyone i'm director sato i'd like
to take this opportunity to tell you all
about the much requested extra game mode
included in resident evil village
the mercenaries for those of you hearing
about it for the first time
it's a beloved extra mode featured in
various games in the franchise
it's best known for speed arcade style
action
where you have to reach the goal within
a certain time limit
of course we've also added some new
touches to it so let's dive into some of
the additions we've made
welcome
in this version of the mercenaries you
can access the duke's emporium between
areas you're free to purchase new
weapons with the money you collect
or upgrade your arsenal to fit your play
style
i saw you eyeing that one weapons
modifications and we'll do thank you for
your patronage
rest assured you can expect this side
move to be just
as fast paced as the previous
installments
you'll have to consider which weapons
you'll take into each stage and how
you'll customize them
with a large arsenal of options to work
with it's up to the player to figure out
what strategy works best for them
another change is the addition of
abilities
abilities can increase the damage of
handguns
or increase your movement speed
they can also make your guard stronger
each increasing the player's
capabilities
acquire new abilities to employ your own
strategies
as you fight your way through each stage
the mercenaries in resident evil village
is a rich gameplay experience full of
surprises
with special rewards for those who
persevere
if you're looking for an additional
challenge we hope you're excited for
this extra mode that's included with the
main game
it's a challenging and rewarding bonus
mode packed with content
so we hope everyone is looking forward
to it thank you so much for watching
if you haven't already heard resident
evil has reached an impressive milestone
on march 22nd the franchise celebrated
its 25th anniversary
and like so many of you i've been a fan
it's practically day one
together we've watched the franchise
evolve from a series of survival horror
games to a big umbrella
of video games movies toys board games
and more
resident evil reverse is just one of the
many ways capcom is celebrating that
anniversary
lots of you probably tried the open beta
earlier this month but don't forget
resident evil reverse will be available
for free to anyone who purchases
resident evil village
the franchise has also inspired change
and evolution in the video game industry
as a whole
let's hear from some industry
powerhouses here to celebrate the 25th
anniversary of the resident evil
franchise
i'd like to congratulate the resident
evil team on their 25th
anniversary 25 years is a long time it's
been a
true pleasure watching capcom embrace
new technologies and
find new ways to advance storytelling
and gameplay
over the last four console generations
and i can't wait to see what resident
evil village will be like
on playstation 5
playstation
hello i'm ashley swadowsky i'm the
character art director
at naughty dog i wanted to first
congratulate
all of the developers for 25 years
of amazing amazing resident evil titles
i hope that no matter what game you
touched or what part of the game
you are responsible for you've brought
inspiration to
so many people over the years myself
included so thanks so much guys
and again congratulations hello my name
is javon reddy
and i am the studio director at media
molecule
i want to just start out by saying huge
congrats to
everybody who's ever worked on a
resident evil game
um you had me at day one with your
incredible franchise i hope you're super
proud of yourselves
um and um you know really enjoying kind
of seeing
what you know seeing how your beloved
franchise has sort of developed over
over these last 25 years it's awesome so
huge congratulations to all of you
hi everyone i'm hiroyuki kobayashi
producer on live action and anime
entertainment for resident
evil this year marks the 25th
anniversary of the series
having worked as a programmer on the
first title and as producer on several
titles over the years
it's amazing to see how far the
franchise has come
it's a brand name that you hear even in
the movie business
and it's thanks to the love and support
from the fans
to all of you thank you so much
now we have something new to show you
today from one of our latest projects
please sit back and enjoy
never gotten clearance to land that fast
before
you must be special
[Music]
leon claire could you
take a look at something
a little boy drew them i can't get
anyone to go on record
doesn't that look a lot like raccoon
city
i gotta go don't do anything stupid
hey leon that outfit doesn't suit you
let's get the president to the bunker
anything even remotely hostile gets a
head shot
what did you think i'm happy we're
finally able to share the latest trailer
for resident evil infinite darkness with
you today
starring leon and claire it takes place
in 2006
approximately two years after the events
of resident evil 4
a zombie outbreak is happening in the
white house and the president
is none other than the father of ashley
graham from resident evil 4.
he's just one of the many characters
that we'll be introducing along the way
so please stay tuned resident evil
infinite darkness
will be airing on netflix worldwide in
july
2021 and i have one more announcement
for you
related to the live-action reboot of
resident evil
filming in toronto has wrapped up and
we're in the middle of creating the
creatures in cgi
so please stay tuned for more
information including the release date
until next time thank you for watching
hi on behalf of everybody here at
behavior congratulations
on 25 years of horror over the years
our very own 4v1 multiplayer action game
dead by daylight has become the hall of
fame of horror
and today i'm excited to say resident
evil
will soon be joining our universe now
tune in to our fifth anniversary
broadcast on may the 25th
for the full reveal of the resident evil
chapter coming to dvd
this june in the meantime if you're up
for it
i suggest you get some practicum before
the chapter comes into the fog
because look you have two choices here
kill
or be killed it's your call
well we're not quite finished yet here's
one more announcement that's taking
resident evil to a brand new point of
view
let's take a look
hi i'm mike morishita executive producer
at facebook
resident evil the franchise that changed
the way we think about video games
is still going strong after 25 years
congratulations capcom
on this incredible milestone
now let's rewind for a moment i remember
when resident evil 4
launched in 2005 it was amazing
brilliant nobody had ever seen a game
like it before
and it remains at the pinnacle of the
survival horror genre
in the 16 years since the launch of
residual 4 the gaming industry has
evolved
and new ways to play have entered the
market and we've been eager to explore
how of four could be enhanced for a
modern audience
i'm mike perdue vp of content at
facebook reality labs
i'm excited to announce that capcom
oculus studios
and armature studio are partnering to
bring resident evil 4
to quest 2. we're thrilled about this
game we can't wait for you to experience
the world of resident evil
in a new medium it's immersive comes
with a first person perspective and will
bring new richness and depth
to the resident evil 4 experience you
know and love you'll be able to step
inside the game
for the first time tune in to the oculus
gaming showcase
next week april 21st for more details on
resident evil 4 vr
how we brought this title to this new
medium
and you can check out some additional
gameplay footage as well
you can tune in on the oculus facebook
page or on twitch
and that's it for our showcase let's
recap the exciting news from today's
event
resident evil village releases on may
7th and a demo experience will be
available for a limited time
each week leading up to the game's
launch playstation owners can
pre-download the demo starting today
the mercenaries mode was also announced
with a first look at gameplay
this fan favorite will be included with
the game and
finally to celebrate 25 years of the
franchise
we have resident evil infinite darkness
coming to netflix
and new upcoming collaborations with
partners outside of capcom
thanks again for spending some time with
us today for another exciting showcase
i'm your host brittany bronbacher and
it's been an honor being here with you
again and hosting this event
have a great day
bye
another time
my
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you